What
are you going to
do by
bringing me to this place?
I'm sorry, everyone in the village,
I'd
rather kill you than to hear about it
.
I think I'm going to die Poor thing, I'm going to
die
But that's all it takes
A body with Venus in
it Eyes that make you feel intelligent
Fine skin, rose-like cheeks and lips
Overflowing and not knowing how to stop I
was born to see such a beautiful woman  It's the
first time that
there are humans who can understand
my beauty.The fact that you chose me means that
you needed
something beautiful.
There were multiple candidates, but you were a unanimous
vote.
The eyes that look at me are also strangely passionate, and if you look closely,
you don't feel
like you're
quite
handsome.
What is Iloca and how do you do it?